[Musique]
fillon merci d'avoir accepté d'être
venus si on va se faire avoir une bonne
discussion avec quelqu'un qui a un
parcours qui m'impressionne beaucoup
pour avoir fait pour avoir eu le rêve
olympique moi même
puis être conscient de ce que ça prend
pour s'y rendre premièrement
félicitations pour tout acquéreur tant
que 2020 ça se passe je suis allé pour
commenter pas de liège je vise
kovy ali pour comme comme analyste parce
que tu as commencé déjà la carrière de
d'animation à la télé quand je trouve ça
et je trouve seul j'aime vraiment ça
fait longtemps que je veux faire ça dans
la vie je pense la première fois qu'ils
ont moins interview pour une performance
sportive que je devais parle à la caméra
j'ai regardé la fille j'ai fait comme
pour cela d'un pied j'adore parler de
plongée est à tout en même temps
oui 1 - k way
jusqu'à
les mamies bac es
c'était c'était possible après tout ça
c'est trop certains n'y avait pas nous
ou est-ce qu'on étale avec crainte en
sport études est ce que l'on est et on
était au peps à l'hiver ça va on
étudiait à quatre endroits qui est une
école en basse ville
puis il ya vingt premières de plongeon
même françois imbeau-dulac italie
olympique
j'étais de l'autre il était blessé je
pensais pas aller en 2016 ce petit
arriver avant 2005 c'est tellement
dommage juste avant la qualification
olympique françois glisse sur la planche
ce mal dans le dos peut participer pas
et ça peut toujours une blessure tout
été blessées ou si je pensais à huit
mois
péter est pauvre et je pense que ça a
été la pire année de ma vie
oui juste parce que moi dans ma vie j'ai
été très chanceuse dans ma carrière
j'étais jamais blaise moi j'ai eu un
fort bon j'avais mal au poignet j'ai un
peu mal dans le dos mais jamais quelque
chose qui m'a empêché de m'entraîner
plusieurs jours consécutifs
et là on est à huit mois des jeux je le
sais que c'est mes derniers jeux
olympiques à vie en carrière et le
docteur m'a dit ce qu il faut qu'on peut
mettre dans la plante pendant deux mois
ça veut dire que je peux pas plonger
pendant deux mois et ma qualification ma
dernière chance de me qualifier pour rio
étaient dans deux mois
ouais fait que celle je peux trouver
drôle c'est juste l'entraînement à sec
l'entraînement qu'est-ce que tu pouvais
forme et dans le fond ce que
c'est aussi là que j'ai réalisé que
j'avais une équipe de feu eux ont fait
autour de moi ça va gérer la nutrition
gérer ma tête j'ai mes rendez vous gérez
tilt ou le médical tout le suivi avec
mon coach de plongeurs ils m'avaient
amené en clinique me faire faire une
boîte pour aller dans l'officine à j'ai
regardé mes muses alerte que l'homme a
même
mon mollet ilité s'est atrophiée mais
que je perds pas les masses musculaires
fait que j'ai continué à tous les jours
à m'entraîner avec soit ma botte dans
l'eau ou en dehors de l'eau à faire
la visualisation mes plongeons les est
fermée puis hier c'est tous ces faux
puis dans le dans ce sport là comme la
natation c'est la même chose il ya des
essais olympiques près puis les essais
olympiques c'est au canada sûrement
plongeon que je me souviens des essais
olympiques de 2012 en natation qui
étaient au stade olympique
et j'avais assisté à ce que j'avais
jamais le cèpe le sport de la natation
est quand même plus gros qu'elle
plongeon parce que les estrades étaient
remplis si un tel timing
c'était l'autre puis c'est vraiment
hallucinant
ces questions en seconde puis à bord
vraiment pour la mecque plus ultra de du
des nageurs qui étaient assurés d'y
aller même si qu'il faisait une
contre-performance mais tu es obligé de
faire une grosse performance pour deux
qualifiés pour les infections que si tu
arrives dans sa cette journée là où
est-ce que c'est ton épreuve pour la
qualification
pictet of cette journée là il n'y a pas
de deuxième chance qui s'est terminée en
plongeant par exemple il ya un système
de pointage qui se cumulent tout au long
de l'année pour justement pas envoyer
quelqu'un qui sort de nuire aux jeux
olympiques et pas de constance qu'il
faut que l'athlète est démontré une
bonne constance en performances tout au
long de l'année même l'année précédente
qui permet d'accumuler un pointage est
ce que le contraire fonctionne aussi
est-ce que ce site est un athlète qui
accumule un bon pointage mais que ça
flop complètement aux essais ce qui est
une façon d'y aller quand même
ça dépend des autres sites a accumulé
assez points pour que personne puisse te
rattraper que même si tu rates
sinon il ya quand même une bonne
bataille généralement là entre les entre
les athlètes pour par exemple si une
plonge je me prendre comme exemple en
j'avais fait des bons pointages mais
j'étais un peu en deçà de ce qu une
plongeuse avait fait et qui étaient mes
gains mais guen avait déjà son spot
quasiment confirmé tellement qu'elle
avait fait deux points durant l'année
mais moi je me battais contre une autre
fille je devais absolument gagner
l'épreuve pour aller aux jeux olympiques
généralement ils prenaient parce que
megan thiney la deuxième mais tu es pas
des gens duo avec megan j'allais déjà
pour y aller en solo solo créé l'épreuve
exactement je vais absolument gagner
c'était la première fois que pour une
compétition
j'avais pas de j'avais pas de changer
deux spots tv je sens le stress comme un
acte a menti c'est elle la ronde
préliminaire avec des points qui se
cumulent donc les dix plongeon que je
devais faire les dix comtés ouais ouais
cette offre doit arriver le choix de ces
compétitions le soir des finales mettons
le vietnam en termes de thiais en termes
d'effort physique c'est pas lâche la
chose la plus longue et physiquement
mais si le stress mental tu sais quand
le sport psychologique ça n'a aucun bon
sens complètement sa tête épaules une
journée c'est fichu le fais moi je
dirais que le plongeant ses 80% mentale
et physique
vous avez tous des psychologues sportifs
sûrement oui c'est seulement la natation
te des meilleurs témoins bonne journée
mais titre plonge dans l'autre fait
qu'on mieux petites touches petit regard
des tanks de fait mais en plongeon ton
petit orteil et par andré collet klaus a
changé de pied qui aussi qu'hier c'est
un sport évaluer sa part jugé une chose
qu'on contrôle pas la natation 8
contrôler sa vitesse contrôler ton temps
il ya personne qui peut je pense pas
tricher tonton
des arbitres qui peuvent dés fois
prendre des décisions avec l'égalité pas
d'accord mais c'est plus rare
si on défile fondu exactement fait nous
il ya d une partie qu'on contrôle pas
donc you're so qui entrent en ligne de
compte mais c'est c6 très sain c'est un
plongeon à la fois la compétition plus
heureux j'écoutais un documentaire sur
tom délit plongeurs anglais puis lui une
fois ya raté ou aux à l'épée qui sont
admis son plongeon twist j'ai pas trop
le moment le il était bleu képi à chaque
fois qu'il faisait ça chie jeu ce qui
est arrivé pour lui c'est qu'est ce
plongeon là c'est ça s'est passé dans sa
finale chez eux jeux olympiques
ils voulaient qui gagnait alors ouais
mais y'a un flash dans les estrades qui
parle donc pas pour ça que quand tu
arrives dans une piscine faut qu avec un
flash parce que ça dérange les adultes
on voit des despotes de l'union qui
dérange on peut se perdre c'est ce qui
est arrivé c'est pop perdu mais ça le
dérangeait et c'est son premier plongeon
effectivement ils demandent au juge
garde j'ai ce qui me dérangeait le choix
du leur faire et disent oui il refait il
réussit puis à partir de ce moment il ya
plus jamais été capable de refaire ce
plongeon le lieu d'en apprendre un
nouveau parce qu'à y était c'est fou
c'est vraiment fou et qui finalement à
rio le y allait pour l'heure pitt arrive
et fait les records du meilleur pointage
le matin aux mineurs puis après c'est
son mental a décroché il a fini 18e
finale dans les estrades à regarder on
était l'équipe canadienne que les
classes on est super proche mais très
bon ami fait qu'on ait tout ainsi les
uns à côté des autres
les autres compétitions exact mais c'est
vraiment juste dans l'eau non mais c'est
super amical blanc n'avait plus de
compétitions avant puis ont regardé
porter comme pour que tu en fasses la
finale il ya besoin de 10 pour toutes
les juges aux gens de riez pour son
dernier plongeon
ça lui il est capable
mais les chances que ça n'avait été que
c'est rare finalement il a complètement
raté comme un des meilleurs au monde ne
frappe pas la finale olympique dont
piquante et comme un nid contre lui
c'est sonic on may bowles il est reconnu
comme comme athlète partout dans le
monde
impossible de se déplacer sans se faire
remarquer oui la pression qui sera fort
ça n'a aucun bon ça ouais c'est là que
tu vois que tu es tout en 2008 en chine
tutu le but le vécu michael phelps
c'est là que tu vois à quel point les
exploits que lui a réussi au courant de
sa carrière son sont sûres et elle parce
qu'il ratait jamais choqué et jamais
toxiques
cai a fait une contre-performance fait
que jaro 400 cas n'aurait aucun sens car
anges à londres est arrivé 4e qui est
une contre performance mais c'était
c'était mieux
même lui son coach de 10 le temps qui a
fait c'était mieux que son niveau
d'entraînement c'est parce que cette map
entre énerve en 2012 disent tellement
pas entraîner les émirats triet wayne et
y avait il ya un effet de la partie un
petit peu trop après deux heures mais
j'ai vu des photos à l'appui gros dos
meiway est épicé que lui a jamais fait
il jamais de choquer jamais non puis une
carrière sens-tu ok j'avais ces foules
étaient très rares
il faut que ce soit fait pour que ce
soit tellement sûr de soi sinon ouais
c'est que là ça a été toujours arriver
est ce que tu as des anecdotes de
moments d'une chope ou de huawei qui
justement les jeux olympiques c'est sûr
parce qu'il ya personne qui peut te
préparer à ce que c'est les jeux et
sûrement aussi le regarde à la télé moi
j'ai toujours rêvé à ce moment avant de
savoir ce que ça voulait dire les
olympiques je regardais à la télé je
voulais être
puis tu vois des anneaux partout où tu
iras est empreinte pour sopi roman
d'annie quand arrive qu'en dis tu vas
aller aux jeux olympiques au recueil ses
hôtes mais tu le sais encore passer quoi
tu en arrives pas la mort en arrivant là
bas en chine il ya des anneaux partout
et tout le monde te rappelles qui était
aux jeux olympiques et c'est la plus
grande compétition de la vie qu'il n'y a
pas d'autres niveaux après sa facture
arrive de [ __ ] et tout ça tout le monde
tous les journalistes veulent te parler
tout le monde tout d'un coup a le goût
d'être ton ami
fait assez particulier puis le moment
que je suis monté sur la plateforme aux
images faisaient le plongeon synchronisé
seulement avec avec meg puis enchaîne
toutes les puissances disent la piscine
était tellement grande
les estrades montea je sais pas jusqu'où
y avait peut-être trois fois c'était
immense tout le plongeon dans water cube
exacte et le plongeon est le sport
national polonais cd spectateurs très
bruyant bah ouais fait que le premier
plongeon qu'on montre qu'on nous annonce
j'avais les jambes checker j'ai capoté
parce que c'était même trop gros ce que
je pouvais
c'est une fois que te briser la glace ça
va bien qui une fois que tu es un peu la
compétition évidemment moi je sais ce
que je veux c'est pas mal ça se passe ni
aux jeux olympiques arrivent labo
tabarouette tout le monde est bon fait
des compétitions pour gagner autant que
tu vois moi tout le monde s'entraîne en
train la mitidja maschmeyer que c'est du
aulas je les ai toujours battue j'ai
toujours battus tarifs demandés tout à
fait 2-1 ça surprend parce que tout le
monde est bon peut-être pas le droit à
l'erreur jamais puis c'est vraiment le
tout au long de la compétition voyez que
personne raté puis on se mettait de la
pression se mettait de la pression ça
d'accord on a fini 7e
[Rires]
ouais ce que c'est parce qu'on était
j'avais quand même pas mal d'autres
après ouais non c'est sûr mais celle là
pour ouvrir celle de gens l'ont le
touquet - mais cela tellement et cela
tellement est énorme c'est moi j'ai
juste fait j'ai fait trois essais
olympiques bancaire puis j'ai fait une
fois une finale aux jeux olympiques
c'est un top 8
puis il ya ce qu'on appelle le match au
fait que c'est comme la parade des
athlètes puis mon sujet qu'on le match
ok c'était le moment le moment était
beaucoup trop gros pour moi le sais j'ai
écouté j'ai fait j'ai fait une bonne et
sur une grosse contre performance juste
pour faire tomber ce thème dans le
moment où est-ce qu'il faut que tant
façon mes petites marches plus y avait
les estrades étaient pleines à une
compétition de natation des estrades
pleines jamison ma ville et et puis
c'est juste trop gros si le moment était
juste trop gros je t'ai pas prêt pour ça
puis ça je suis mais la marche avant ces
pays même au sud dans la compétition les
présentes citons maman de mai
c'est le moment où cette lettre temps à
penser est ce que ça va faire ce break
ouais ça fait moins mais tout le tage
hostilement blanc avant la présentation
tout comme c'est tellement l'on sait
qu'en plus cette analyse les autres
quand et le même si je parle fort qui
sait qu'il doit presser car hadopi comme
une espèce de man games aussi dans ce
que tu veux avoir la relaxe je veux
avoir leurs postes respectifs et des
jobs mais en faisant des jo que tu sors
de ta zone c'est que c'est toute façon
été choisi pour ce très jeune au cul
ouais puis quand je tends ma compétition
quand je plongeais avec avec megan tout
ce qu'on faisait songeront jaser un
écouteur dans chaque oreille puis on
jasait mais de tous et d'airasia avait
aucun rapport avec le plongeon juste
atteint qui appelle non
on jasait way tenait dans les
entraînements notre coach est elle au
bord de la piscine au sifflet pour
arrêter toute façon ce pilote vaudois
akilov attention assis à ses côtés
je m'en défaire le tricot staff entre
les deux systèmes - là l'astrée system
et game qui fallait comme sorte de deux
monstres comme d'habitude ça va avec
à partir de là ça mais le fait que ça
allait mal était en guillemets ou en
ça fait carrément 2012 tu sais quoi
ouais pilot ouais tout à fait parce que
quand on est arrivé à londres en 2012 on
s'est dit mais je le sais c'est quoi
je le sais à quoi m'attendre je pu
impressionner de qu'est ce que c'est les
jeux olympiques c'est moi je me dis
qu'ils avaient trop jeux olympiques mais
après trois choses différent c'était la
première c'est l'expérience
la deuxième c'est la performance que la
troisième jeudi c'est la domination mais
c'est là où je me laissais à l'effectif
l'expérience nous a servi pour beaucoup
à notre deuxième expérience aux jeux
olympiques puis ça fait toute la
différence quand tu vois des nouveaux
duos que à part des exemples vraiment
précis punique seror le monde qui sont
vraiment bons à leurs premiers jeux
olympiques il ça arrive et barry tout le
temps où deux personnes qui ressort du
lot qui on parlera par naïveté
oui parce que j'ai peiné leixia comme
ses fonctions normales le mur d'enceinte
des athlètes le temps
quand on n'est pas capable d'accoucher
et pascal rien à perdre
la première les athètes en général ça
met beaucoup de pression parce qu'ils se
disent peut-être que c'est ma seule
chance
ouais mais elle arrive le halo 16,1
alors rien à perdre
encore dix ans car c'est juste le cialis
à fonctionner ses premiers jeux
olympiques qui était bon métier avec un
esat arrivée il t'arrive 4e ou 200 fly
away à 15 à l'aller d'après faisaient
records du monde quatre ans plus tôt
regagner un scénario d'or deux d'argent
ouais y en ait qui piquent à 15 16 ans
17 ans après ce serait cela est bloqué
le spirit of le sujet là j'avais j'avais
la liste des gt médaille internationale
puis la liste des tortionnaires à soucht
de 2005 à 2012 commence et ce comme
commencé pour un athlète qui met en
dehors parce que c'est sûr que t'as pas
mais je sais pas exactement c'était quoi
ton régime d'entraînement à ce moment là
mais c'est surtout au ralenti tant que
ce tir ont en fait
en fait j'y gagne des médailles les
années de ma carrière c'est jusqu'aux
championnats du monde aquatiques
entre 2005 et 2030 1013 je n'ai pas
gagné
championnats du monde j'en ai gagné nos
grands prix les séries mondiales mais
les championnats du monde aquatiques
qu'elle ait jamais la fina c'est exact
je finissais toujours 4e est ce que
c'est si à part les olympiques
si la gauche c'est la grosse compétition
comme recommandation à chaque deux ans
et ce avec quatre exactement ya surtout
tous les athlètes sont réunis tout le
monde est là c'est un mini jeux
olympiques hmm hmm je regardais même
hausser les communes world pour les pacs
y'en à ces années là non plus il n'y
avait pas deux
sur la liste des mecs et j'ai regardé ça
arrivait pas non plus que c'est encore
le même principe d'une quatrième place
une cinquième place
j'ai gagné des médailles ouais oui entre
entre 2005 et 2013 j'ai fait les paroles
les panam en 2011
j'ai gagné une médaille d'argent la
l'egypte comme nos soucis non c'est pas
vrai les jus de commandes du pôle de
médailles j'aimerais parce que
mais parce que ça m'allait c'est
deschamps car j'avais pris le relais en
synchro avec une autre figure itep
habitude qui est sûr que ça c'était un
dernier megan a décidé de revenir aux
cominois 3 jours avant le départ
cependant place une chimie des années
est possible je les fait parce que les
pays devaient participer puis que c'est
une tradition pis correct mais je les
ports fait après c'est un long processus
il ya beaucoup de compétitions en
plongeon il ya beaucoup de circuits faut
toujours performer faut toujours
améliorer puis il ya tant on teste des
choses ça marche des fois ça marche on
s'est fait cueillir une période où ça a
été un peu plus rough dans la carrière
même si j'avais quand même des bons
résultats mais j'ai l'impression que
dans ma carrière j'ai comme été à mon
meilleur
vers la fin dans les quatre cinq
dernières années c'est là où j'étais le
meilleur
alors que l'om 4e 2005 j'ai plongé
pendant 20 ans j'étais sur l'équipe
nationale depuis que j'ai 14 ans fait
que
c'est un petit peu à reculons petit peu
justement en 2005
je me rappelle toi tu travailles et
j'étais là j'étais présent j'étais
bénévole monde aquatique l'aiguade un
peu l'équivalent de celui qui je
ramassais les paniers de linge qui n'en
font les athlètes font leur part à
l'expérience et j'ai rencontré tous mes
idoles
j'ai pris des photos avec sauf michael
phelps on avait il y avait une once they
fait dit explicitement
n'approchez pas michael phelps il était
jeune le lancement a eu lieu mais
c'était tout après les olympiques de
2004 puis c'est dangereux au monde à
cette époque l'homme il faisait
tellement charly matteï a dit le détail
tous les bénévoles tout le monde
personne doit m'approcher dans le
village des athlètes sur mondialement
connue pour faire sur la place
nadal tous ces gens les joueurs nba
il y avait un bateau il se tait loin les
quais de la nba le trim team qui
appelait les six ont loué un bateau de
croisière parce qu'il voulait pas être
dans le village avec moi si je pense
qu'ils sont à challes et tout le temps
même par les athlètes se souvient
d'avoir vu lebron james en ligne au mcdo
en 2012 pita vite de mon ami les
athlètes l'ont spots et s'élancer au
mcdo c'est là pour performer compétition
paul goût non ça je crois monsieur
qu'elle comprend complètement état si on
est à la caf thereon manche dont l'un
est assis juste à côté de lui y mange et
là on veut le voir on veut une photo on
veut lui parler tpiy il dit lochte après
manger deux fois après sa mort le corps
est mais ils se poussent pas parler au
monde mais moi j'ai un novak djokovic
qui sourit à tout le monde
pas gentil même usain bolt il s'arrête
pour jaser show men c'est quelqu'un qui
clame un kit arlette c'est pas tellement
ce n'est pas ce qui était un athlète de
mes romans
kiki est un peu et trouver un peu gêné
mais qui prend le temps de les prendre
une photo j'accueillais mais tant qu'on
prend l'exemple des joueurs de tennis on
s'entend que les olympiques gagner les
olympiques au tennis c'est un petit peu
une cerise sur le sundae mettons les
pieds alors que tout capté gran slam ou
est ce que gagne et ça c'est plus
prestigieux pour les joueurs de tennis
prend l'exemple de michael phelps gagner
le soutien et les charlots du monde
c'est même moins 6 et moins haut que les
olympiques victorieuse olympiques c'est
la chose qui s'est accomplie je peux
comprendre qu'ils mettront djokovic se
promène dans le village puis trip parce
que à lausanne un pic la vie de village
on en parlera plus tard les salopettes
malade mental ce drame iphone lui je
peux comprendre qu'ils volent un peu
pour le triptyque s'amuser aux
olympiques
mais c'est quand même sérieux pis pour
eux ils ont une pression de bien
novak djokovic qui est qui dans le top 3
mondial tout le temps où ça bouge
souvent que le yari vous allez pepy
c'est les couleurs de son pays comme une
taxe et autant de pression petit tu le
vois qu'il se donne autant dans un grand
tournoi mais pays
c'est sûr que socialement lui est super
avec un ronaldinho qui était le puits
qui prenaient des photos avec tout le
monde sait ça varie de sport enfants
roger federer et aux jeux olympiques je
veux pas se faire écoeurer puis il ya
aucun problème mais il reste à l'hôtel
ouais c'est sur ce mail pas ma
conférence pourrait faire ça s'il veut
vraiment aller au mans il ya des moyens
peau enfin ça dépend ce qu'il fait
voilà mais on allait parler justement
2005 ça a été votre votre bic ça a été
la que vous êtes sorti un peu nous le
port ouais surpris tout le monde
complètement folle et provient social
est honni highpoint des carrières
sûrement complètement c'est quand on me
demande c'est quoi les meilleurs moments
de ma carrière
outre les médailles olympiques oui je
suis extrêmement fier d'eux seuls le
moment qui m'a le plus marqué c'est
celui là moi c'est les chaleureux du
monde à montréal en 2005 mais guinée -
un chien de jeu juste d'avoir 18 ans
megan à 16 ans on est les veaux qui de
l'équipe nationale on à alex despatie et
émilie heymans riquier journalistes
veulent pas nous parler parce que à quel
point tu es bon train dans l'ombre de
ses soeurs pinoit à l'abandon n'est pas
supposé d'être là parce que on s'était
pas qualifié au niveau individuel puis
en synchrone été chanceuse parce qu'il
n'y avait pas d' équipe vu que c'était à
montréal ils ont décidé de nous envoyer
l'équipe hôte comme
c'était chez nous ils ont pris
l'opportunité de nous envoyer il s'égare
dans ta maison sac doit pas nous coûter
belle expérience premiers championnats
du monde seniors fait que à la maison
devant famille et amis puis si je
comprenais pas l'ampleur de cette
compétition je t'attends qu'eux mêmes et
gay mois au monde sur sur le dit m j'ai
pas un show qui sait si qui met quant à
la feuille du canada sur ton costume de
bain tout le monde en a appelé non puis
je mets ma main qui disent non non ils
ont vu monter sur la plateforme la foule
c'est milla qui n'avait aucun bon sens
j'avais jamais vécu quelque chose comme
ce film le premier réflexe est parti à
rire mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont invité
ici parce que cela dépend des cas mais
ils nous connaissent comme à sortir
c'est notre première expérience mais
finalement
puis encore leur un peu comme ce qu'on
disait sur les olympiques ou au peigne
et alexia qu'on n'avait rien à perdre on
est là pour s'amuser pour avoir du fun
puis ça finit que on a gagné la première
médaille de ces jeux là devant tout le
monde et ça ça levé à partir de ce
moment là les gens ont commencé à nous
reconnaître à s'intéresser à nous suivre
un peu ouais puis vous êtes en marquer
aussi dans le dans l'espèce de deux
vagues qu'on reconnaissait les plongeurs
canadiens
oui c'est une tradition des plongeurs
québécois particulièrement qui
traduisent une performance dans le sens
où 8 au 26 juin dernier une annie
pelletier presse alex despatie et émilie
heymans et le ces deux là est encore sur
l'équipe il y avait au grain fillion qui
poussait qui pend au nez
puis à partir de ce moment là je pense
que la tradition des performances a
continué à mener à partir de cette gêne
à bell continue à performer pendant
tu es plus de dix ans après après cette
compétition le fait qu'il a bien
poursuivi
qu'est-ce qui fait c'est ce que c'est la
qualité des coachs des techniques
d'entraînement aussi un intérêt poli
québécois pour le plongeon qu'est ce
qu'ils voient qu'on peut dire je pense
qu'au québec on est très très bien
m'installer pour s'entraîner en les
meilleurs entraîneurs au monde je pense
qu'on est et dans les villes autres la
chine le hades sur l'île de montréal il
ya plusieurs pistes d'entraînement
valide pour s'entraîner avec une
plateforme de dimanche si on a le simple
aura bien le stade olympique la piscine
à pointe claire maintenant le parc
jean-drapeau fait déjà noté il ya plus
d'offres pour s'entraîner si un problème
sur une piscine et les entraîneurs sont
qualifiés sont très bons et puis je
pense qu'on est bien on était bien
encadré et puis est ce que toi dans le
fond tu es entrée est-ce que tu étais
sur l'équipe nationale
avant 2005 j'étais sur l'équipe
nationale
avant 2005 j'étais géant trait sur
l'équipe nationale en 2003 j'ai fait mon
âme et 2003 2004
la pire saison de ma ville c'était
vraiment horrible je plongeais pas bien
j'ai pogné un flat jay scratch et ça
tout planter mon année j'ai connu flatte
les plus complètes des scribes le flat
de 10 mètres ou bouger panier un vrai
gros flad trois mois est figé ça fait
mal sous-estiment pollet l'est la
douleur
non ça coupe le souffle des bleus vous
savez ça m'a empêché de finir la
compétition et donc qu en cas d'angine
doute à l'obstination de notre bassin en
danger je t'avais le plonge dans l'aube
[Musique]
justement de l'année 2005 j'avais perdu
c'était une bonne façon pour moi de
faire comme bas et je pense que j'ai
regagné mon puis je peux dire que ça
fonctionne comme la natation avec le
code est cool moi c'est quelque chose
que je voulais et je voulais qu'on
aborde avec toi parce que souvent au
canada admettons on regarde les zones et
p puis j'ai l'impression que la tendance
globale du monde qui regarde les pics un
peu de prendre les athlètes olympiques
pour acquis en guillemets parce que on
regarde sur puis admettons moi je suis
je travaille comme technicien
informatique dans une boîte puis je
regarde je te regarde plomb jeux
olympiques
il me dit à moi je suis technicien
informatique mais roselyne et plonge
sauf que le fait de dire rosiers
plongeuse roselyne à un gang sa vie avec
sur mes agrès pas un vieux sa vie est
technicien informatique qui sait que
nous on prend pour acquis que six
athlètes le bain aux autres la
population générale s'en prend pour
acquis que six athlètes là et sont là
ils gagnent des médailles c'est cool
pour le canado team et le travail qui va
derrière ce c'est pas une job c'est une
c ça prend plus de temps qu une job mais
c'est pas
une job le monde qui ont la chance que
tu as eu de la chance
le talent et le travail d'être aidé
d'être sur l'équipe nationale d'avoir un
revenu mensuel par plongeon canada le
gouvernement et le gouvernement est
davantage équipés les athlètes qui sont
sur lequel nationale mais reste que ces
poteaux des millions de dollars avec le
plongeon non et c'est moins 46 personnes
yes la saison suivante je suis blessé je
performe pas j'en ai plus de code s'est
couché pour te rendre pour te rendre
jusqu'à l'équipe nationale tu doit déjà
faire énormément de sacrifices pour te
rendre jusque là et avoir une chance de
peut-être puis ce jeu savoir toi dans
ton parcours comment ça c'est fait
est-ce que tu as eu un moment j'imagine
que tu un support parental jusqu'à un
certain point ce qui n'est pas le cas de
tout le monde soit aujourd'hui qui peut
avoir ce monsieur c'est avec thunder pop
vendangeurs qui disait des dépôts
peuvent y en a tout les coins de rue
c'est juste qu'ils ont jamais danger oui
c'est juste qu'ils n'ont jamais eu la
chance de faire le talentueux j'en ai vu
- des athlètes devoir arrêter de plongée
parce qu'il y avait plus de sous pis au
cesag sûrement de haut calibre est bon
ou un jeune âge que les parents ne
peuvent pas tes qui s'épaulent seul
enfant de la famille y en a d'autres
aussi qu'il faut que quand des activités
un moment donné ça devient que c'est
beaucoup de sous puis on peut remarquer
si tu t'en sais c'est pas tout un habile
non c'est pour être capable de marquer
pour la famille c'est ok c'est une
activité où tu dépenses de l'énergie
parce que moi je crois dans la vie que
l'on doit faire
pique moment donné tu réalises que ok 2
1 j'ai un talent un mais deux jeux très
belle trop en faire ça tu es moche
période de ma vie fait qu il ya ce
moment là où tu dis bon à ce que je me
mets à fond oui bon c'est les parents
qui doivent un peu prendre la décision
parce que c'est eux un jeune âge qui en
bourse tout les sources eur puis à un
moment donné à la vie adulte dit bon
est-ce que comment je vois me gérer pour
moi partir dans la vie mais ce que je
commence ma vie ou et où je vis depuis
je me ferais tout ce qui entre en ligne
de compte dans mon cas - gt gt vraiment
chanceuse que ma famille a été là pour
me supporter avant que j'atteigne
l'équipe nationale une fois sur l'équipe
nationale ben là c'est d'apprendre à
gérer ses sous juste au cas où je perds
mon statut l'année suivante ou peu
importe qui dans le sport amateur
les compétitions ne rapporte pas de sous
ou est ce donc se fait en bourse
y'a pas de bourse il est et où il ya des
bourses que tu fait avec la fondation de
l'athlète d'excellence du québec sont là
pour te supporter ça c'est si tu vas à
l'école va pas à l'école tu peux pas
voir ça y est le comité olympique
canadien dans le top 4 vont donner une
bourse quand tu performes quand c'est
pas des années olympiques il ya des
moyens d'aller chercher des sous un peu
partout la commandite est extrêmement
difficile pour le sport amateur et cc
c'est vraiment à moins d'être le nom le
gros nom doit être les gros noms - dames
anse part j'avais deux gros noms
c'est comme ça que je parle avec th pris
tout le monde à n'importe qui d'un mois
1 argent et notamment qu'au fond de moi
du nord gens sont bloqués deux mois un
plongeur alexandre despatie des mois
deux plongeurs bleus qui m'a jeté le
monde sait ça ce quinté 2e tout le temps
tu es un des meilleurs au monde
c'est un taxi qui le deuxième que marché
salue youri gagarine jusqu'au mariage
personne personne aucune décision et en
même temps mais dans mon sport + à
évoluer plus le circuit s'est améliorée
ou y est apparue des séries mondiales
les séries mondiales des médailles a de
l'argent et une bourse pour le fait
qu'ils pouvaient selon tes performances
mais encore le footsie gagne des
médailles pour avoir ici c'est donc moi
là dessus j'ai été chanceuse j'ai gagné
des médailles à pratiquement tous les
compétitions donc ça m'a permis de me
partir dans vie puis c'est à la fin de
ma carrière j'ai eu des commanditaires
et s'est rendu tout est rendu plus qu'un
autre plus qu'une athlète je ne peut
aller que despatie
non mais j'ai les lèvres
et puis moi dans la vie je me suis
toujours dit je fais je fais pas du
plongeon pour l'argent si les
commanditaires me veulent pas parce que
peu importe la raison
ça me dérange pas moi ce que je veux
dans ma vie c'est gagné de médaille aux
jeux olympiques c'est peut être la tête
d'affiché d'une compagnie ne suis pas
contente qu'une compagnie m'approche
pour me disait tu veux tuer notre
ambassadrice n'a pas le rôle peu importe
si on veut de commandite et j'adore ça
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui croit en
moi de l'extérieur qui me connaît pas ça
j'aime vraiment ça mais en même temps
mon but dans la vie c'est ça m'empêchait
potes de n'empêche que par contre jeux
olympiques laisse une méchante grosses
industries paraît été tièdement par tous
de voir le monde qui écoutent ce jeu de
grosses les grosses argent qui se
brassent la baule les grosses compagnies
qui sponsorise les justes les droits de
diffusion mettant de radio canada
la 250 millions ça leur coûte il doit
être difficile
qui sait un petit joueur parmi d'autres
le train pas qu' énormément beaucoup
d'argent qui se fait là puis le show
c'est vous qui le faites dans un sens
c'est drôle parce que l'horaire des
compétitions d'étendre la diffusion en
chine les finales le matin pour qu'on
puisse les regarder les faits pour
directx était vraiment beau evènement à
regarder pour les athlètes une
expérience incroyable sauf que l'argent
que vous donnez aux autres tout est pas
là pour donner un spectacle mais c'est
un spectacle en ce sens les gens et que
moi j'ai les mains les sports d'hiver
c'est un show pour moi je me lève la
nuit pour le regarder je trais barrère
directement sauf que là les seules
personnes qui sont paraît il mais relate
dans ses spécialités et à la sala les
pics une entreprise privée le cpo une
certaine organisation hearts est une
compagnie dont le but fasse des profits
fait que le fait qu'ils aient témoin qui
montent un spectacle de même s'armer
reese les athlètes sam et callen peu
meilleurs clients viennent bien bon côté
à sa par exemple parce que le mouvement
alain pécoud le comité international
olympique où je pourrais pas dire
jusqu'à quel point ils font des profits
là dessus mais parce que son
organisation pour aider les athlètes
dans mon cas moi j'ai pas débourser
aucun sou pour me rendre nos jours alain
picq il même à ça c'est pas plongeant
cadre c'est pas l'équipe nationale
non ces lézards et pefc baiia comme
l'est
le cio le coc donc le comité olympique
canadien aussi toutes ces organisations
le font en sorte que les athlètes dans
des bonnes conditions
allez hop la formule faut ranger
performer en tulle à chaque fois
d'argent exactement ce qu'ils ont
ça dépend le riu y avait des petits
problèmes de
logement mais moi je n'ai pas eu trop
trop conscience mais on n'est pas on
n'est pas à plaindre non plus et des
bonnes conditions on vit notre à un
moment donné faut oublier ce qui se
passe au taux puisse concentrer sa
performance que de travailler toute ta
vie tous ces clubs c'est clame je dis
pas que c'est à l'heure c'est à
l'athlète de de phase iib révendications
lol c'est parce que l'athlète doit se
concentrer sur son entraînement sa
performance qui vivent son rêve
justement puis à la retraite y prendre
tout le temps qu'il veut pour faire
comme jean-luc brassard je tenais ce
qu'est ce qui fait l'italie en entrevue
à dutrisac puis finalement il est
complètement déboulonner toi j'ai lu
toutes les conceptions connu que des
olympiques mais en même temps si ce jeu
vraiment pas enlever ce dans le sens que
c'est un super bel événement puis pour
les athlètes c'est incroyable ouais mais
c'est encore c'est juste dommage que l
arrêt venir à 100 si on regarde les
sports professionnels oui ou le plafond
salarial et d'année millor ce sont les
baisses bolloc'h et les faux de bas mais
le football canadien un peu moins mais
c'est le gap est énorme entre qui on
dépense le même la même énergie les
mêmes non plus quipo rénumérés de la
même façon qu'un joueur d'araki qui
prend sa retraite y est correct pour le
reste de sa vie
à moins que face aux cavs
mais la fête amateurs c'est recommencer
à zéro
me suis rendu j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
le sport universitaire pour poursuivre
des études et en même temps puis je me
suis rendu jusqu'au bout de mes cinq
années universitaires puis jusqu'à ma
dernière compétition je faisais encore
des mers temps des meilleures
performances et meilleure performance à
vie jeter le meilleur athlète que j'ai
été toute ma carrière à la fin puis j'ai
toujours dit si la natation devenu un
sport professionnel après l'université
comme peut le devenir le football par
exemple je prend corps dans l'eau en ce
moment c'est parce que en et arrive tu
es confronté
moi j'étais confronté a cependant un bon
5 1 le jardinage à 26 ans de 21 à 26 sur
garde tes amis qui ont on mange le thé
amis ils sont en cours puis pense avoir
des enfants
élégance leur job rémunéré à 60 mille
pièces avec un bac par année play
commence à avoir des assurances d'antan
l'assurance médicaments commencent à
avoir des conditions de vie de quelqu'un
de 22 23 24 ans commence à avoir plus
tout est là tu dis bon qu'est ce que je
fais à soir ben là je me couche pas ce
que demain matin je m'entraîne depuis
qu'est ce que je mangerai logement
chaussures parce qu'il faut que je
récupère bien plus pilote est toujours
confronté à ça à dire bon mais c'est
qu'un mois que je commence ma vie c'est
ça tu étais un peu tout seul nazaire
parce que moi je la vis en ce moment
depuis que j'ai plus de mai j'ai pris ma
retraite je m'arrête à 29 ans 30 1 j'ai
une 31 ans je me sens encore comme si
je suis vraiment une débutante dans la
vie tu avais les affaires que personne
qui a vécu tu
sauf que dans la vraie vie comme on
l'entend c'est compliqué mais repart son
ou ses ou que j'ai plein d'énergie j'ai
envie de me dépasser j'ai une rigueur de
travail et non vie aux olympiques tine
revenir et qu'une médaille puis toute
cette attention on le sait le plus gros
reproche que tu peux avoir
mais le crash après d'autres
interventions se retrouvent parce que
c'est moi donner l'exemple
la musique c'est qui justin chau est ce
que ça marche parce que le monde gueule
que celle von der heide sorte d'écran
qui puisse pas l'enquêté comme un genre
qu'il est encore jeune âge en veut plus
mais là c'est fini c'est le show est
fini pis y'a plein de musiciens et
d'artistes qui font la bise à l'équipe
qui tombe soit en dépression ou dans la
drogue
enfin et comme ma carrière j'ai eu
vraiment une période très difficile
c'est quoi la circumambulation rebuts
dans la ville accompli après semaine que
ce fait bref j'ai regardé le
documentaire sur netflix de riga la
préparation à sa performance au super
bowl à 10 pour un artiste show la plus
grosse vitrine le après ça je vais aller
dans les petits stades par un spectacle
et comment je vais me motiver à faire ça
c'est la même chose pour un athlète
qu'est ce que moi je veux revivre aussi
ce que je veux accomplir d'aussi gros on
m'a dit quand j'allais avoir des enfants
que peu
un croate et un gros clash et
j'ai essayé d'éviter le crash mais j'ai
pas pu danser inévitable parce que la
réalité de frappe d'un vêtement dans le
sens où moi je suis revenu de rio je te
souhaite aller faire promet un jeu tout
de suite allé à l'université j'ai lancé
mon entreprise avec ma famille s'y fait
je me suis dit je veux m'occuper le
cerveau comme si j'oublie ouais mais
toute mon énergie pour ça ça pour ça
pour que j'oublie qui agit un peu de
terre moi je vais aller faire d'autres
choses des conquêtes et le centre gauche
pique est à peine arvier par ailleurs
moment donné je me suis juste dit bah le
vent je reprendre se relaxent je veux
prendre du recul je veux penser à mes
enfants je veux le vivre mon deuil je
vois le vivre ma peine je veux le vivre
mon nom mon crash puis après ça ça va
pas ça passe
- le tapis l'at elle est encore la peine
l'institut des fois où tous ces pseudo
c'est sur deux ans j'ai pas eu aucun
regret d'avoir pris ma retraite j'ai par
curiosité demandé à mon coach
à la fin de l'hiver si j'ai commencé en
septembre il était trop tard pour pour
pour tokyo fait simplement par curiosité
de voir combien de temps ça me prendrait
pour revenir mais j'étais simple
curiosité mais quand je ferme les yeux
je pense à tout l'entraînement que je
dois vraiment pu la transition va bien
le voit partout même partout on le voit
tout ce que collaboratrice havre ac
entre oui je vais toujours plus c'est
toujours ça mon problème richard veut
toujours plus j'en fais jamais assez
mais j'adore ce pas réussi ce qu'il faut
que j'apprenne à gérer que je prenne une
étape à la fois ma carrière d'athlète ne
s'est pas bâtie à hull 1 la carrière
d'animatrice et qui ne se bâtira par une
entité faut que je me le rappelle
souvent que roselyne ça prend du temps
c'est correct fac c'est ça que je trouve
plus difficile à gérer que moi je
voudrais en faire tout un sens ice pour
m'améliorer plus vite pour monter plus
pour continuer je mène en vie en général
mais
j'apprends je sais c'est la beauté de la
chose c'est que oui j'ai vécu une belle
carrière sportive mais je continue
d'apprendre tellement dans un autre
domaine et dans une autre partie basse
allemande celle de l'athlète de vous
laisser dépasser d'être compétiteur une
compétition de compétition puis ouais
c'est ça reste dans les hautes sphères
de ta vie d'après moi je pensais que en
arrêtant la compétition j'allais arrêter
d'être compétitifs parce que je me suis
gardé assez compétitionner dans ma vie
j'ai pu rien à me prouver c'est correct
fait ça pour le plaisir
non il aux défauts que je sois bon à tel
ou tel moment fouquet j'ai le meilleur
cadeau servier cycle art ciné je peux
pas marcher mais je sais tellement
j'étais tellement compétitif puisse
cesser de mon âge ensemble on t'aime je
suis prêt je me faisais j'acceptais pas
de me faire battre par la personne à
côté de moi être mauvais perdant
j'étais extrêmement je sais pas non gt
gt gt j'aimais vraiment pas super
finition c'est comme ça puis une fois
que je perdais je peux pas dire je
t'aime mauvais perdants sauf que je t'es
pas content oui c'est vraiment pas puis
je faisais tout pour ne pas perdre
puis autant des fois on jouait juste au
soccer dehors l'été et il s'en sortait
de moitié puis dépendant que tu es à
occupation double justement les a amenés
ici il nous explique qu'on va faire des
compétitions pour une place en finale
plus que moi j'ai fait non je veux pas
faire ça je veux pas avoir cette
attitude là parce que je savais que
c'était à moi depuis que j'avais fini le
danger cet avis était pas sorti the
chill en tout ce que je faisais ça les
bains
mais même au bon objectif avec un but
précis qui passait en double tu es un
peu en compétition ouais ouais
et puis en même temps faut pas que tu
déranges les autres quêtes faut 50
personnes ça dérange c'est toi c'est la
seule personne que ça dérange quand tu
sens que tu entraînes de perdre si toi
tu peux pas le dire tu peux pas en
parler
les fous que tu joues ça avoir l'air de
ge wind ben faut que tu fasses sauf que
tient encore le principe de noir mais
non c'est clair que ça sort pop qui
avait annoncé sur mes cheveux je pouvais
québec au complet mme voyais pas de
mauvais temps forts y en a tellement qui
nous ressemblent c'est qu'ils vivent la
même chose que toi ou qui ont la même
personnalité effectuer même si au pied
c'est peut-être un faux bon côté mais
les gens vont s'identifier va dire ben
c'est peut-être est au courant
verbaliser qui tu sais mais les gens
vont plus attachés que la puis j'imagine
que c'est une force quand tu arrives
dans un parce que on s'entend que la
télé est quand même domaine compétitif
quand parce que du monde qui veulent
cette position là il y en a beaucoup
c'est faux soit la meilleure je suis le
plus à offrir au studio parce qu'ils
m'ont font la file pour avoir un poste
l'été le monde veut être la prochaine
véronique cultive balmont c'est
marie-pierre ma fille tu es dans ton que
edward beaucoup de plongeuse qui rêve
qui aspirent à a commenté le jeux
olympiques
beaucoup d'ex plongeuse je t'explose
genre casper à être sur les ondes puis
du monde qualifiés mais c'est drôle
parce qu'on en parle pas beaucoup
de ça moi je dirais que met-on l'analyse
est arrivé dans ma vie par accident
parce que moi je me suis dit annie
veulent faire pendant jusqu'à pas
qu'elle soit attaqué
23 sous traitants cavell mais c'était
tout de suite car moi j'ai pris mandela
me l'avait dit a dit moi ça me tente
plus de le faire c'est toi qui veulent
faire ok je pensais qu'un jour ça allait
arriver mais suit mais c'est sûr qu'à un
moment donné tout le monde les athlètes
la rue en général veulent travailler
dans l'immédiat après on le voit avec
les joueurs de hockey mais non c'est sûr
que c'est un milieu très très très
compétitive face à cette force à trouver
des façons doit être la meilleure
version de toi quand tu arrives dans des
plateaux comme ça est ce que toi tu te
quand quatre sud chan ms qui est une
préparation extrêmement strictes pour t
moi j'y suis préparé comme si j'allais
compétition loin ouais je peux pas moi
je peux pas arriver puis peut être prête
je peux pas arriver puis pas savoir
méchant je peux pas arriver puis
[Musique]
un laisser-aller l'improvisation plus
juste me dire marc jeu peut jaser
pendant combien commencement c'est sur
le je parle de moi mais quand j'ai
quelque chose à gérer ou admis ou à
montrer aux quais de la préparation
derrière c'est ce qu'ils aiment en et je
me plante puis c'est pas bon ce que je
fais pas scoré que ça arrive mais c'est
pas parce que je te préparer c'est juste
parce que mes circonstances ont fait que
je me suis planté
mais je trouve ça à la limite qu'ils
n'ont plus difficile de me préparer
comme ceux où de faire de me préparer à
animation peu tendre et peut-être parce
que je prie consciente que j'ai le goût
de ça puisque je le sais que je sais pas
si à mon âge c'est un peu plus difficile
de faire son chemin
aussi c'est juste que moi je me met trop
de pression mais j'ai l'impression que
pour moi physiquement mais bon c'est
certain
exact mais c'est pas l'envié qui manque
puis c'est pas le goût qui manque non
plus jamais vraiment été bonne pour une
facilité quand même des athlètes qui
sont quand même extraverti ou de choux
gras de parler puis de bien s'exprimer
le seul tu le fais pour un fake c'est
pas tout le monde que cette chance le
cette aptitude aux plaintes et à la
porte quand que tu étais encore
plongeuse oui oh oui très bien beaucoup
de fous rires passe par gène clé sich un
peu gêné j'ai le jeu le rire facile
c'est sûr que quand je les regardais
après jetée comores mais
mais c'est sauter ça fait partie de ma
personnalité je dis qui je suis puisse
être habillée par battre les projets
ckoi lexovien cgu un été très tranquille
contrairement à tout ce que j'ai vécu
dans ma vie fait que ça m'a fait du bien
j'en profite je te vois parce que
j'étais c'était là que ça se bosse exact
les étés à montréal j'ai connu ça
de ma vie je m'en fais que même les
dépasser j'avais beaucoup de choses qui
arrivent et en même temps puis j'en ai
vraiment pas profité fait que cette
année je me suis dit j'en profite
pendant que c'est tranquille puis je
veux juste faire ce qui m'etonne alors
profité je vais aller un peu en vacances
profitez de la famille les amis un peu
de travail ici et là parce qu'ils
avaient travailleurs autonomes c'est
qu'une photo le passé c'est pas de dire
je prends trop un mois de congé journée
fait que j'en ai et j'en ai profité pas
mal puisque j'ai mon entreprise de jeux
d'hiver
merci à commencer par ses sites
allemands
c'est tellement beau et c'est tellement
inusité pour comment c'est arrivé mais à
chaque fois que je parle d'être ça aux
gens me regardent comme toi c'est que ma
cousine s'est marié en 2015 et pour son
match de paris on a décidé d'aller faire
une journée d'activités puis les jeux
d'évasion est la voulais pas être dans
rue avec une banderole brandie devant
dix ans sous préfète manque au fait à
qui on ne fait une journée d'activités
puis les jeux d'évasion faisait partie 2
sort n'avait jamais fait ça avant
on l'a essayé un gang on a trip efforts
qui après cette toute la famille
on a décidé d'aller faire un peu tout ce
qui existe à chaque week-end les enfants
1 2 3 dépendamment de l'horaire a
complètement vient plus dans la période
où c'était c'est un peu un vers les jeux
de rio
pour moi c'était un exutoire une heure
le j'oubliais tout un problème je suis
même allé avec ma patte dans le plat
offert un jeu d'évasion jambes et qui
vous fait que cela n'est pas exact
moi j'adore s à décrocher pendant une
heure puis de me prendre pour une
chercheure peu importe dans un scénario
de la prison de la banque
peu importe j'ai tripé benzène montfranc
qui est un gros gamer geek jeu vidéo
didier a toujours voulu se lancer en
affaires et fait une petite réunion de
famille chez les hommes on se faisait un
super entre frères soeurs cousins
cousines
puis il dit je pense qu'on peut se
partir en affaires c'est l'ancienne
compagnie en famille de jeu d'évasion on
a tout dit oui fait que chacun avait
quelque chose de différent on gagne
vraiment créatives ont créé nos jeunes
ou les énigmes
est-ce que vous avez plusieurs zoning
qui roulent en même temps quatre
scénarios qui roulent en même temps avec
les scénarios différents
puis ça va faire deux ans au mois
d'octobre qu'on est ouvert
pis là on continue à travailler là
dessus en ce moment les étés s'est
occupée il faut que je chantais concept
parce que tout le monde revienne aussi
sûrement exact mais encore le nous on
pensait qu'elle nous concept allait
durer un an
c'est le temps qui a déjà affirmé qu'ils
ont plus longtemps que celles beaucoup
de gens qui ont jamais fait de l'évasion
piqué
ce qui arrive quand j'avais en jamais
entendu j'ai jamais fait pas longtemps
qu'on entend parler d'un jeu d'évasion
j'ai peut-être commencé à entendre sauve
le pij palais on va y aller
mercier dessus présents sur place deux
fois oui oui et oui cela quand même
régulièrement
oui c'est pas moi qui la roulade mais je
suis là une fois de temps en temps
je fais partie je roule les affaires
l'on participe ont créé les scénarios on
veille à ce que tout se passe bien
construit les enfants ouais c'est pas
une personne bonne manuel pour faire des
trucs mais on me montre bien mais j'aime
ça j'aime vraiment ça c'est un côté
créatif que je pensais pas que j'avais
mais c'est sûr que à la gamme qu'on est
on the band personne va sortir une idée
ou vice versa fait que je pense qu'on
est une équipe complète vraiment bien là
tu fais que ce sont deux gars de ça me
garde bien occuper la gare de kipé
horripilé dans le fond l'entrepreneuriat
c'est quelque chose que tu avais en tête
depuis un bureau de vote je n'ai jamais
rêvé à ça j'ai jamais jeu mais je me dis
tout le temps j'ai jamais eu la fibre
entrepreneur j'ai jamais dit moi je vais
partir de business joueurs faire quelque
chose c'est que vous êtes mon propre
boss très importe j'ai jamais pensé à ça
mon frère au contraire lui a toujours
voulu se passe qui m'a un peu tiré là
dedans puis j'apprends j'apprends
complètement sûr sur le tour c'est
vraiment comme ça on fait les erreurs on
apprend des trucs puis j'aime vraiment
ça c'est complexe etc c'est beaucoup
d'heures non comptés ouais mais
mais c'est tellement valorisant de voir
les clients sortir de la pièce qui était
dans notre tête puisqu'ils ont tripé
bear head on a des supers bons
commentaires sont nos scénarios sur
l'accueil tu sais quand tu viens chez
merci à tous rentrer dans ma famille
c'est un peu ça notre concept et on sait
là c'est l'accueil c'est on voit
vraiment de prendre en charge
on jasait tout un feeling sur place fait
que c'est ce qu'on veut c'est que si on
veut pas que tu rentres tu joues pit
stop il n'y a pas eu d'interaction sont
intéressés à savoir c'est qu'en mettant
les thématiques des scénarios qui perd
là quatre oui alors on a le week end au
chalet ça c'est vraiment notre plus pop
la huawei
on ne le cabaret piccadilly
qui est devenu cabaret l'on donnait des
années 30 on a world inc est ce c'est
une compagnie qui s'est associé à guy
mercier pour vous faire vivre une
expérience de voyage dans le temps et on
à la station oublier ça c'est une
vieille salle de contrôle d'une station
de trait alors ouais ouais c'est cool
c'est quoi le pourcentage des gens qui
réussissent on se situe entre 10 10 et
15 16 % de taux de réussite le
dépendamment du scénario mais on est
quand même bon parce que dans certains
endroits pour pratiquement impossible
qu'il ait une chance qu'on a fait ou si
c'est dans notre recherche
on ne fait plusieurs jeux d'évasion puis
on a pris ce qu'on aime puis on a pris
ce qu'on aime pas d une évasion se
l'approprier moi ce que j'aime pas c'est
que à 30 minutes j'ai l'impression que
je sais que je vais perdre fait dans nos
jeux à nous tu as toujours l'impression
qu'a tu avances keaton chances de gagny
pitt est potes déçu quand tu gagnes pas
tu es déçu mais tu étais tu sais que tu
étais une proche des faits mieux ceux
qui entrent en ligne de compte mais pour
avoir une belle experts mais c'est super
cool moi je trouve trop gens changent et
d'évasion je crois peut rire de moi des
fois que c'est un peu comme des valeurs
20 mai dans le sens où on s'attend pas
sûr non c'est ça c'est que c'est
surprenant puis les gens qui n'ont
jamais fait va peut-être jugé un peu
cette activité le pic qu'un kit bond
l'essayer vont trouver votre n'a pas
besoin d'être pc le jeu vidéo pour
tromper sommer dévalorisant aussi de
réussir à trouver un indice complètement
titre
et pis t'as pas besoin de bons en maths
pas besoin d'être bon physiquement
simplement de l'observation pour un peu
de logique mais le cerveau humain est
phénoménal c'est qu'ils te pose
tellement trop loin est-ce que vous avez
des caméras pour regarder moi on voit et
on entend ça des fois tu dois tu dois
parlement pas dire complètement cerveau
y est allé jusqu'à l'os
l'office des eaux la fin d'une belle
activité pour une équipe sportive qui a
le goût de vivre de quoi en sambou et
des collègues de travail
c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment l'idéal tout cas ne fait
vraiment beaucoup maintenant quand tu
vois une place est-ce que c'est facile
pour toi est ce que tu vois les les
indices les codes des obèses tout le
temps pas du tout c'est que vous êtes
bon prof ça veut pas dire non non j'en
ai fait un il ya deux jours puis on la
pourrit si le sait ça ça arrive c'est
sûr qu'on a une observation peu
différente puisque j'avais un peu comme
regarder comment regarder mais
n'en reste pas à chaque fois j'en
faisais un compétition dans les autres
pays
or c'est que l'appareil avait pas toutes
les parties dans le monde à rio il y
avait un jeu l'évasion
à cocody
quand j'avais quand j'ai fini ma
compétition j'ai mené ma famille on
avait fait un à haut débit sur place
ouais ben arfa c'est dans les
compétitions que je parlais tantôt avec
une compétition c'est sûr puis j'en
appelle année on ouvre une boîte le y
avait des photos c'est les photos des
anciens candidats d'où des pilotes
chercher un chiffre à 4 un code à quatre
chiffres plus sur les photos il y avait
des jets en arrière des fois il avait
déjà lors sur quatre photos y avait des
gens se disaient là on était content
d'aller trop loin en détail troublant et
marquée c'est lesquels photo qui agite
supplice la quatrième la 7e la huitième
puis le jardin devient plus que ces
chiffres le sachent quoi finalement qu'à
regarder les photos zhao des droits
affectés là on essayait de trouver la
pire affaire on est juste allé trop loin
c'est la clé du succès ce l'égard des
cinq points c'est vraiment ça est-ce que
des skis comme des experts du monde qui
sont mettons qui est funky et
craquements dans sur youtube l'étude et
youtube harkis fondé non non ils
pilonnent delà de ça parce que je sais
que gabriel d'almeida freitas qui
nourrissent la relève lui c'est est
infâme de tulle puis m'expliquer que y
avait vraiment des trucs et lui avait
des trucs tu sais quand tu es tu avec
les autres parlent à voix haute qui dit
tout ce que tu voyais plus quelqu'un
vous recevoir l'information a mené en
checkant quelque chose d'autre qui voit
comme parolier une veillée qui a compris
comment travailler en équipe
ouah ça il faut pas que tu aies laisse
rien de côté rien n'est laissé au hasard
dans la pièce si lui y compris ça c'est
déjà bon c'est la peau de
mais il n'y a pas de tricheurs si tu
triches être schéma temps mais cette
force sur les choses dont on peut voir
et d'essayer d'en pas de réponse sur
internet ou sur n'importe là mais si lui
il s'est trouvé une manière de
fonctionner c'est ce qu'il faut faire
ouais c'est bien c'est fou mais je sais
du monde
moi j'écoute et je me rappelle que cet
hommage se rappelle pas c'est quoi son
nom mais c'était sur youtube le gars il
était reconnu pour sa logique fait qui
comme il voyait quelque chose y voyant
un problème et ont un problème de
mathématiques mais tombe qu'ils étaient
capables de résoudre sans savoir la
formule que ça prenait pour le résoudre
parce qu'il déduisait la formule lançant
son phénomène des déductions était un
homme bon et mercier ben si ça mais je
me demande si je me demandais s'il
y'avait pas quelqu'un mais tant qu'ils
étaient connus pour du monde qui t'ont
connu pour être vraiment bon si je
l'étais du monde qui déclenche tout
maintenant y en a d'autres qui ont des
meilleurs pourcentages de réussite dans
plusieurs jeux là on a vu ça je pourrais
pas dis pas ce que je fais je suis pas
dit groupe i qui mais c'est de l'avant
mais nous on a reçu des gens très
crinqué de jeu d'évasion et qu'on les a
vus c1 qui détiennent le record de
tonneaux 5e puis on ne le garde pas de
bons c'est nous qui étaient proches non
dans l'est on doit modifier puis après
ça on reçoit dans ojjeh bonne dame
nature
c'est juste 16 ans ont vraiment créé de
ces surprenants appareils de voir des
gens qui ont la logique il observations
le très bien développé ouais
puis ces écoutes ça me fait penser à te
poser une question que je voulais te
poser avant le manque on parle de jeu
d'évasion et lorsqu'on parle de travail
d'équipé ouais un sport individuel comme
le plongeon qui devient un sport d
équipe
en plongeon synchronisé suivre et puis
au delà de justice
mettons qu'on fait on joue au hockey
dans une ligue puis huy at-on bantam peu
importe on change d'équipé à chaque
année comment tu fais pour trouver
l'équipe hier l'homme sort de l'ombre
sort le plongeon comment c'est arrivé
votre rencontre et mégane philippe nadon
parce que on se connaît on se
connaissait et on s'entraîne et
ensembles à vent
au sein de faudra bien qu'à mélangeant
cas moi j'ai comme j'ai commencé au club
de plongeon laval j'ai ensuite été à
aucun moment j'ai fini ma carrière au
club de plongeon point qu'un puis à ce
moment là on est jeune on a la même le
même entraîneur on fait les à peu près
les mêmes plongeon on a un peu la même
technique puis notre coach nous dit
ben y'a pas des clips synchro pour cette
année au canada
on va vous mettre ensemble voyons voir
ce que ça donne et le son on est à peu
près au mois d'avril mars à avril alors
j'ai 17 ans et il ya la coupe canada
annuel qui te sentir bien à chaque année
maintenant au stade olympique mais
pauvre en calories et c'était là notre
première compétition ensemble
international ont fini sur le podium le
la semaine suivante on est en fleuret le
premier grand prix qu'on est exposé à
l'est de façon individuelle
ils nous disent fait le synchro on gagne
une médaille d'argent
les deux camarades
c'était un adam c'est un match parfait
puis un coup de foudre entre autres
mégane et extérieur l'extérieur un coup
de foudre amical on est devenu des
soeurs on dit c'était
ça c'est très particulier comme relation
puis jeudi toute assez la relation la
plus mais non pierre si d'autres
systèmes montréal 2005 salades mais
marché évoqués bien marché c'est à dire
et 12 ans et sa wii est ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire le 12 en est fière on
est le duo féminin le plus
des carrés de l'histoire du plongeon au
monde est celui qui a duré le plus
longtemps
alors ouais crime and started blanche
way qui est ce que est ce que des
moments où est-ce que l'extérieur a fait
que ça aurait pu lâcher mon psy chic
année on sait jamais on sait pas
chicaner tant que tu y a des fois que ça
a été plus fort que d'autres qu'on
voulait pas se parler puisque j'avais
besoin de chacun de son bord mais
vraiment poste non t on quand tu es
jeune
on aime un peu tout les mêmes affaires
ou des mêmes choses longue comme
vieillir ensemble développer nos
personnalités qui sont très différentes
avec on a appris hier
c'est drôle à dire mais à s'aimer malgré
nos différences on avait pu les mêmes
champs d'intérêt que quand on était
jeunes puis à respecter ça puis c'est ce
qui fait au moment de la confrontation
on n'est pas toujours d'accord sont les
mêmes choses mais
on s'accepter comme on est est puis on
s'accepte encore comme on était fake
ça fait que ça fonctionne et puis on se
dit les vraies affaires aussi c'est ce
qui est fait en sorte que ça durerait
aussi longtemps c'est qu'il est con on
le disait cumule pas quelque chose c'est
l'oeuvre se tuent tant qu'africain
l'accumuler puis qu'on faisait rien
puisque l'on ne veut s'exposer
puis un moment donné c'est juste bon
garde le saf et le poste de vice versa
de son bord puis maintenant tu es je
peux la lyre 5 à 10
j'ai vraiment l'impression que décrit
une relation de couple un mois c'est
carrément à se lancer car emma stone
mais oui mais c'est megan c'est ma soeur
et c'est une partie de ma famille je
suis une partie de sa famille c'est ça
c'est assez particulier fait tu fous sur
moi puis on a vécu des choses tellement
intense que personne d'autre peut dire
que vie qu'ils sont un peu con s'ils
n'ont pas voté contre 36 à huawei fait
que senna fait deux ans que la dernière
composante cinquième anniversaire
si on était marié mai mais non c'est
qu'il sait comme c'est vraiment comment
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est un duo ça
fonctionne ce plongeon mais ça
fonctionne pas au niveau des
personnalités qu'est ce qui fait la
force
c'est rare que ça dure et on a vu des
duos se se défendre au fil des eaux fil
des années puis pas parce que ces
personnes le sait mais pau soit que ça
marchait pas ou une arrêté l'autre
continuer ou des blessures oui dans
notre cas c'était un parcours assez
assez similaire puis on était deux
plongeuses qui performait bien au niveau
individuel aussi fait qu'à
l'entraînement d'avoir quelqu'un du même
niveau c'est la meilleure façon en
premier parce qu'on se poussaient les
deux même si on se retrouve à
compétitionner ensemble mais
le lendemain on était une grosse l'autre
puis j'ai je suis mauvaise perdante dans
la vie mais j'aime pas perdre le goût de
loeb j'avais le goût de la battre elle
avait le goût de me battre mais c'était
très sain dans le sens où je l'appelle
javel et mais la pilule quand c'est
megan qui me battait qu'une fessée c'est
parce que je le suis je la vois à
l'entraînement je le sais comment est
mort c'est fake c'est pour
ça ça me dérange un peu moins en solo
c'était hautement être aussi mais 5,7 m
existe us oui c'est à l'entraînement
qu'on utilise dans les compétitions
juniors qui surtout mai
les jeux olympiques c'est seulement sur
le dit m puis naturellement vous êtes
rendu compte que vous aviez vous été
meilleur le web complètement moi j'ai
jamais par des auteurs et
dans ma vie je pensais que j'allais aux
olympiques au 3 mai mais ce que j'avais
vu un appétit et puis je voulais faire
j'aime pas de références mais quand j'ai
commencé à faire de la plateforme j'ai
fait aux deux mois ce que je voulais
faire
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qu'on en
question qu'est ce que tu penses du
tournant du plongeon vers le sport
extrême avec l'arrivée d'un gros joueurs
comme red bull qui rendent dans ce
timing du monster ces affaires-là qui
rend le plongeon eu un petit peu plus
mainstream si on veut bien ces deux
parts complètement différents mais la
plupart sont des anciens d extorquer des
acrobates des anciens plongeurs surtout
je connais beaucoup de gens qui j'étais
aux olympiques qui sont maintenant dans
circuit de du haut vol parce qu'une
façon faire gagner ta vie on attend sur
le circuit avec des sponsors que plus
que spider donc pas juste un maillot de
bain mais c'est un dilemme nationale
[Musique]
mais oui ces deux sports complément
différent de un parce qu'elle plongeon
on n'arrive pas sur les pieds moi je
le haut vol c'est obligatoirement sur
les pistes sont sur la tête peut-être
suis vraiment c'est des acrobaties cd
sorte de plongeon convoi peau en général
sur qu'il utilise les techniques de
plongeon pour s'entraîner mais ces deux
sports complètement complètement
complètement je pourrais tellement pas
faire ça deux semaines trop et est pour
le poignet mais moi je suis monté sur la
plateforme de 27 membres du duo vol
juste pour voir
c'est très haut je n'avais pas peur mais
sauterait pas elle n'a pas le vertige à
27 mois non les 10 miles et hall et
humain est une personne normale le
vraiment le vertige
non mais vraiment tu viens tu quand tu
avais quand tu es rentré mais moi je
t'ai paulo mais c'est une histoire qui
l'ont entendu ça vaut la peine raconte
et je pense qu'à terme trouve pas reçu
de ma quatrième année les gueux
d'enfants il vit toujours dans le fond
de quitter en cinquième en éthique été
pluvieux il a listé les petits nouveaux
en plus notre jeune chicoutimi quelle
honte arrivée à québec on avait notre
gros pick up de choc gros pick-up la
campagne de mon père vient porter un
pick-up les voitures volées char de
l'école est une école publique mais
comme spa rituel fait que c'est des gens
aisés
qu'est ce qui se passe je les vois
débarquer de tueur non mais l'histoire
c'est que le plh foule impressionnée
cette évolution est acceptée
chaque oeil à réussir dans la piscine la
ligue homogène vous dis-je capable de
sauter du trimestre 2008 à mettre le
holà pigeât s'était pas tout le monde
qui était game
elle est dûment 33 pieds ce qui équivaut
à un édifice de trois étages
ceux qui savent qu'un peu à quoi
ressemblait ce n'est pas de l'eau est
d'abord sa part hep aussi permet de
hausser nos biens c'est vraiment au très
haut qui sauterait pas non parce que je
le sais que ça va faire mal
en touchant à l'os et même si j'arrive
dans le bon angle les pieds des pointes
et tout le kit ouais ça pardonne pas qui
même les athlètes qui font ceux qui ont
un petit degré qui pot à la bonne place
et blesse
sérieusement élevait temps maudit dans
l'ohl chic et les morneau-ricard je te
mets zotti faisait au village vacances
valcartier avait un spectacle die die
il ya un fusil puis gagner leur vie
comme bayer l'étudiant qui résistent et
l'été il faisait sur olivier marquant
lui a fait des tournées un peu en asie
des spectacles
et le lien fait sa qualification pour
être arbitre je pense oui tu es sorti et
il le fait aussi dans les compétitions
internationales
il est comme juge apprentis et la
demande record était jugé alain picard
avec nous à rioz et puis elle je sais je
connais cette famille depuis des piles
je te dis le mcs soit pas longtemps
parce que ça nous retrouvailles comme
[Musique]
max est ce que ça me fait penser les
arbitres parce que quand on parlait de
ce fait que le plomb de lost un sport a
remis très oui il est la question mais
prudente est tantôt mais on parle on
parle d'autre chose
est-ce que c'est des fois c'était arrivé
te sentir j'ai pas correctement par
rapport à des plongeons pis dans quelle
mesure puisqu'elle est le résultat de
six heures pour toi tu y es 45 c'est ça
tu sais pas dans un témoin ben il ya
plusieurs fois où j'ai questionné les
jolis scores dans les scores en disant
comme cammas était vraie marée à gaz lng
mais tout en sachant où après avoir vu
des vidéos que ton collègue est gelée
santé qui même des fois mon coach dit
leur porte pas attention ça que je le
voyais pomper parce que aussi t'es pas
d'accord
puis des fois parce que ce que j'ai
apprécié mon entraîneur c'est que lui
ite qu'indépendant son équipe it et y
est à fond avec toi puis votre défendre
jusqu'au bout puis même devant les juges
ou la majorité des entraîneurs vont
rester sage sage parce qu'elle est juste
il faut pas les les
les déranger lui au contraire celle vip
est comme ça c'était pas beau c'est pas
comme ça son plongeon était bon ça pas
d'enfer être pas bien notés et et lui
allaient au devant de ça puis à la fin
un petit gars n'est dit att plongeon le
temps pointage aurait dû être meilleur
juge-t-on peut payer je le sais pas
pourquoi
peu importe mais il nous a toujours
appris à laisser ça de côté pierre au
contraire à dire sur une bonne note
moi je veux donner tout pour farcir kate
walsh au hameau de ninh binh
ça m'est arrivé une fois la de regarder
à la télé depuis je me suis fait voler
je sais de voile et la médaille d'or aux
jeux c'est tellement d'offres
ouais moi ma dernière compétition les
chacun des universitaires mon objectif
c'est de gagner un nom à une des
épreuves auxquelles je participe et puis
aux 50 m dos telle est la règle
tu peux pas dépasser 15 mètres sous
l'eau faut que ta tête tu sortes avant
15 h au 50 m dos
sors de ma course je suis premier de
quatre dixièmes de secondes après les
préliminaires je vais sans doute gagné
la finale
puis il y annonce qu'il ya une
qualification dans le couloir 4 à ma
vague à moi c'est moins fait le jeu voit
le jeu j'ai dit ouais c es sur ton
deuxième 25 de dépasser 15 mètres sous
l'eau pour moi dans ma tête j'avais si
on le fait tellement souvent tu dis du
je le sentais que ça valait x j'avais
fait 12 batman papillons sous l'eau puis
xavi qui est impossible que j'aie
dépasser 15 matisse était impossible il
n'y avait aucune chance qu'il soit
arrivé du fait que ont déposé un protêt
puis d'habitude en natation et on peut
le regarder les vidéos qu avant de
prendre la décision même chose qui longe
ont sûrement qu'ils regardent les
regarde jamais les vidéos sont exempts
les y avait pas le droit sauf que ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'il y avait du monde
qui filmait les épreuves pour la
webdiffusion paquet puissent ces vidéos
lettre est disponible sur le bar la
piscine pour que tout le monde peut se
regarder sa course
féculent moi je regarde la course puis
je sors à 12 mais j'avais pas dépasser
jeter l'eau même le dépasser mais quand
je regardais ce vidéo là
il y avait le coach rouge et jaune que
l'apéro qui est derrière moi puis la
seconde qu'on a vu que je suis sorti à
12 mois est parti en marche
les buffalos la piscine je l' ai vu
rentrer dans le bureau des juges
qu'ailleurs sorties sont gelés greer
ensuite rentré au complet étaient
ressortis dix minutes après il revient
le dis j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai pu le
prêteur passé ils ont dû normalement on
peut pas utiliser la vidéo sauf que lost
médaille d'or c'est la vidéo est là
aussi on disqualifie ont valeur gagne 2
teu croche fait que finalement ils m'ont
jamais dit et qu'il arbitre comme terry
qu'avec allait dépasser 15 mai puis
finalement j'ai gagné le choix si la
finale effectue aurait duré perdu la
médaille d'or à cause d'une décision
cela revenait pas
dans un sport qui chronométrique faux
faux faux verts avec qui des fois on est
pas on n'est pas d'accord mais par
exemple pour moi cette fois le step ben
trop évidente la compétition à jouer à
la télé après pineau avait juste coupé
du montage mégane et moi on est dans
l'est dans la salle d'audience
on est au mexique ok
non j'ai pas l'amérique est ok ok on pas
d'un mot mexique puis est arrivée 2e 2e
bloc et qui a gagné les mecs qui n'ont
joué mais on est la pression vos tests
antidopage
on est assis dans la pièce et là on
regarde la télé et c'est la rediffusion
de la compétition non on est comme bon
vous regardez notre compétition le 6 qui
on aurait dû gagner mais on peut rien
déjà une autre médaille publique au
regard de la compétition peut on est
comme mais pourquoi les polaires ont les
buts 2e 11 20 le bon sens ils ont coupé
complètement de la compétition comme si
vous êtes il montrait la 3d la 3d on l'a
souvent les équipes huitième équipe
at-on louis j'entre sur toutes les
équipes sauf nous ayons montré notre
premier plan jean et c'est tout un nom
qui les jugent ces des juges
internationaux ou mexicains et
internationaux
ouais pourquoi qu'il s'en fait acheter
non mais un peu on peut en plus se
rappeler et liffré chiens non les
patineurs artistiques qui font la
performance de leur vie de leur village
français une performance parfaite puis
un juge qui doit pas inciter ou deux
comme je sais pas c'est quoi les scores
à un pasteur les russes y perdre y
perdre la médaille d'or mais finalement
c'était déjà mené des mois plus tard ils
se sont fait de donner la médaille d'or
avec une excuse puisque seuls deux jours
après j'étais sur place parce que ces
sorties qu'elle s'était fait acheter ait
imaginé dessus mais c'est comme dans
toutes les dames agrippe l'écart option
d'un sport comme dans tout les domaines
qui ce soir là j'ai tellement du site
était tellement fort
ouais mais on est sur le podium pervers
grosse aurait pareil quand on n'a pas le
choix mais à l'intérieur on le sait que
gagner mais les jeux panaméricains après
on peut bien en chine parce que si les
chinois soient gardés à l'oeil mais pas
besoin d'un chien les chinois
est-ce que cela natation chez que
souvent mettons aux olympiques
c'est à deux nageurs par épreuve par
pays souvent maintenant luc la personne
qui arrive si ce n'est plus vrai
maintenant des années de michael offer
je l'aimé la personne qui arrivait
troisième c'était pas la troisième
meilleure au monde parce que la réalité
c'est qu'il y avait quatre américains
qui ont les quatre meilleurs temps au
monde sauf qu'il y en a juste dit qu'ils
sont dans l'épreuve est-ce qu'ils en
plongeon par exemple au 10 m est ce que
si la chaîne avait le droit d'envoyer
dix personnes se seraient les dix ans
que les deux projets phares tâche en
soutenant beaucoup
je pense pas être à l'aise mais sont
tellement le bassin tellement grand
population qui semblait fâché qui tombe
même niveau au même niveau sinon
meilleurs joueurs de la sélection
olympique d'autres youtube quand je
plongeais les nationaux chinois piges je
fermais sur toi
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose mais c'est foot c
foot parce que mettons que tu faisais un
championnat du monde mais littéralement
un championnat du monde tout le monde
sans limites par pays tiers des sports
qui le laisse qui font jean la norvège
fréjus où tout le monde le sait déjà ils
sont le ping ang et chaleur du monde
trois médailles d'or mais le droite trop
médaillée sûr pas dire mais on doit 3
qui regardent les jeux olympiques visuel
qui est arrivé de visible je suis
vraiment meilleur oui mais cela c'est ce
même pour nous plus jeune des fois on
regarde les autres pays qui ont eu un
spot olympique et on est mieux performé
que mon pays
là j'aurais été premiers mois puis si tu
regardes les justement les olympiques et
justes en natation par exemple dans les
semi finale qui sont les 16 premiers qui
sont ultra relevé gaza drop vie est
apprécié et il est plus que 16 personnes
et peut-être 50 60 par épreuve sauf que
après ça décembre c'était du monde qui
des africains qui ont un spa de natation
mais qui ont jamais dans une orgie sans
lunettes
j'avais visité au jeu mais c'est le fun
parce qu'à la fin tout dit ya de la
place pour tout le monde ou jose -
expert inclusif puis les athlètes
encourage à finir leur course c'est un
beau défi personnel aussi le fait de
cette façon là c'est le fun de devoir
aussi puiser moment donné instruction à
la maison puisse empocher ce sera leur
tour bien une question qui revient
souvent quand on parle de sport amateur
puis d'olympic particulièrement sur la
question du doping en plongeon est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui arrive parce
que c'est quelque chose que quand les
branches on connaît est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment ça sert
absolument rien de se doter pour plonger
ben non parce que c'est un support
artistique est un sport où si tu décides
de doper pour avoir plus d'énergie
it va sauter plus haut perte des repères
martial pirate est on entré à
l'entraînement mais ton tu peux faire
plus de volume total s'était dopé je
sais par action
c'était plus lourde sera pas capable de
faire des plongeons prendre la masse ya
vraiment eu aucun avantage à prendre la
drogue comme le plongeon
il ya un hic se sont fait prendre parce
que c'est coiselet parti un peu de
cocaïne pour améliorer ta performance
souvent poussé un plongeon est ce que tu
parles de poids justement qui peut
modifier les repères est ce que toi dans
tes années de compétition est-ce que tu
avais un poids que tu voulais avoir le
matin de la compétition pour que les
rapports soient parfaitement lobant tu
vas rien petit peu c'est pas très grave
mais ça jamais fonctionné en termes de
pur mais c'est sûr quand on porte un
costume de bain avec sa laisse pas place
à sa cache pas grand chose ok mais ça
cache pas grand-chose faculté évidemment
c'est un aspect qui est important que
moi dans ma carrière j'ai eu beaucoup de
difficulté avec mes pour
tout de façon saine dans le sens où je
devais travailler très fort pour avoir
une bonne shape
puis j'ai l'impression que c'est à la
fin de ma carrière que j'ai est celle là
qui s'était tout le temps quelque chose
qu'on me rappeler mais on ne pesait pas
devant tout le monde on me disait tu
dois peser temps pour être bonne
cette mentalité en plongeant dans
certains autres pays où un incroyant
d'entre eux manquaient position certaine
pression de poser devant les gens de non
je pense pas je pense pas qu'il de
pression moi j'avais menti sioniste ans
quand elle me peser ou prenez mon amour
mon pourcentage de gros c'est tout le
temps tout seul avec elle jamais devant
les autres et manutentionné je me
demandais si elle voulait que je partage
mes résultats avec mes entraîneurs
sinon elle devait le garder pour elle
seule justement c'était à cause des
histoires peu intense qu'elle a
fonctionné comme ça puis moi c'était ma
façon de fonctionner si je voulais le
gérer pour moi de l'adelfa de la bonne
façon que c'est elle qui qui qui me
gérait fake pour moi ça m'a aidé
vraiment vraiment beaucoup dans ma
carrière c'est vraiment le fait beaucoup
de différence dans ma vie en général se
nourrir pour s'entraîner faut la prendre
ben oui tellement difficile c'est super
complexe et qui je m'entraîne le faut
que j'ai de l'énergie mais laisse parce
que si j'ai trop manger tu ne t'en tires
lourdes je pas capable dans mes
plongeons mais je plonge toute la
journée qu'est ce que je fais j'ai fait
qu il ya vraiment une éducation à être
fait pour apprendre à bien se nourrir
selon l'horaire de la journée puis ça ne
sert toute ta vie
ouais tu nourris pour la performance
dans ta vie tu vas bien manger c'est
parce que moins de la confiance c'est
quoi c'est ça parce que c'est drôle
maintenant je vaux soit au restaurant je
me commandent un bol de sade pleut les
gens me disent vous reste aux dangers de
la salade mais j'aime ce côté j'étais
habitué à me faire ça ou moi j'aime ce
dont je me prive pas le théier et je me
sens avant le 30 mai
maurice n'habite qui quand il prend ça
fait bien long terme c tandis que manger
quelque chose de vraiment bon c'est
comme ça peut-être avoir un espèce de de
plaisir instantané mais après ça des
fautes sont sympas le champion le nord
c'est un risque et bien margés son
champion tout le temps - c'est vrai
parce que quand tu mets des aliments
instinct dans ton corps tu vaux bien
sentie tellement il des aliments qui
sont bons ce sont six tonnes de pellets
bénéfices qui disparaît lui même qui
tous au fait c'est sauf quand même que
tu sois athlètes ou beaux athlètes de
bien se nourrir fait toute la différence
c'est un longue journée au travail
nourri toi bien pas sinon tu passeras
pas au travail mais c'est la même chose
le temps dans ce ton corps c'est ta
voiture tu me disais que ça m'a choqué
c'est un bon qui m'a très mal comme une
fois tu vois où tu entends parler
d'excès athlètes qui qui ont
complètement échappé ni dit si on me qui
est parce que tu continues à te nourrir
avec athènes un port calorique autant
aussi gros que tu avais quand tu d'en
dépenser 1000 par jour cinq pilotes se
rend compte que tant dépense pas 1500
franchement ça commence à monter je
trouve dur je pense mettons de 30 heures
d'entraînement par semaine
ah si j'en ai fait cinq dans cette
filière j'arrive le soir chez nous je
programme adorent mais parce que je
passais dépenser d'énergie soit géré
aussi fait quoi comme quand activité
physique même un peu de tout - là
j'étais plongée j'étais pas d'autre
choix la côte on le sait que les vélos
les ce qu'il est
peu importe le tout les activités que
les gens sportifs font je n'avais jamais
fait ça avec je me cherche un vélo de
route
j'ai skié pour la première fois de ma
vie l'ue27 soir ouais
mais là je fais et je m'entraîne je fais
un peu boudeuse qu'un peu faut que ça
soit on gagne je peux pas m'entraîner
tout seul je vois pas au gym à courir
sur un tapis ou élever des poules vous
que ce soit encadré gros coup au moral
de groupe
j'ai fait j'ai fait beaucoup de crossfit
mais mon corps est tanné de
forcé par les décharges sopi c'est le
fun c'est vrai j'aime vraiment ça j'ai
jamais vraiment ce parce qu'il y avait
un sentiment d'accomplissement des
dépassement de soi ce que je retrouve
aussi dans le genre de boucaines
d'entraînement super compliqué j'adore
aussi mais mon corps m'a dit les poils
il s'est passé la même chose moi mais
mes deux dernières années jetant jim
cinq fois par semaine puis j'élevais des
grosses charges je faisais du sprint si
des petits enfants me plongeant cette
affaire ultra coin puis puis le jir
commencé à 6 des lots jempy mes
articulations
ils sont brisées par des années à faire
les mêmes choses fait que le jeu fait
autre chose qu'une boîte pour externe
ans et celle ci je pu lever les gros
chars j'ai trop mal dans le dos j'ai mal
au genou
ça reste c'est ça qui part en vacances
je disais tantôt je n'ai pas blessé
jamais mais c'est parce que j'avais
trois spécialistes parce qu'ils
s'occupaient de moi encore loos puis sol
j'ai pu attaquer plus qui me suis tout
le temps un fait que c'est si je veux
avoir mon ostéo pis de masse une fois
par mois c'est bon ça fait ça fait une
bonne différence c'est que j'ai trouvé
comme cet entraînement le qui me permet
de me sentir bien des dépenses et
plongeon c'est zéro dépense énergétique
non ça monte les escaliers
c'est un problème aussi décidé de garder
le fitness dans quand tu fais mettons
j'ai pas dû plonger combien combien
d'heures par semaine m en faisait le
plus et je suis entraîné six heures par
jour c'est des pratiques de deux heures
à peu près une heure et demie deux ans
dans l'eau le reste un peu physique
ma deuxième pratique dans journée même
chose une heure une heure et demie dans
l'eau le reste est
l'exercice physique après ça j'allais
dire que j aime faire de la muscu qui
était un genre de cas mais parce
qu'effectivement comme tel le plongeon
de ces mettons la natation
tu t'entraînes tu fais ton gardiola les
congés d'été tôt priait 10 livres qui tu
recommences a plongé tu dis pas non
c'est pas ça je dois m'entraîner un peu
en dehors je fasse attention à plus tout
mais au moins ça reste après oui la
confiance et ça c'est vraiment important
de faire attention à mon corps puis
comment je m'en occupe
parce que c'est ce qui me suit est tout
à sentir bien ici je te manquer les
leçons ne tapera dans les eps france a
tout le temps j'essaie d'encourager les
gens aussi qui bouge un peu moins de
dire mais c'est parce que quand tu fais
de l'exercice était plus alerte et plus
concentrés dans la vie je trouve drôle
maintenant c'est que je dis le sport
était la source de mes brebis pour rayer
mes problèmes
équitation this way fait que ça me
permet de garder le sport dans ma vie et
c'est souvent le s'est simplifié à
l'aspect physique mais c'est l'aspect
esthétique non sens qui se dit cependant
pour être
même si c'est une conséquence mais c'est
banal comparer toutes les autres que
j'ai c'est le plus souvent de dire aux
gens oui tu le veux peut-être tombé du
baril mais c'est pas pour ça que tu
devrais vraiment pas pour se fait
quitter parce que tu vas te sentir bien
et puis peut-être que tu vas l'avoir
l'accord que ça peut être un objectif il
ya aucun problème mais ça devrait pas
être la motivation première de dire
juste parce que je vais avoir là dessus
je vais faire ce mode de vie c'est ça
des bénéfices dans ta tête sont encore
c'est ça c'est notre style de vie c'est
pas tout le monde qui va de faire
attention le sport
loin d'un support professionnel mais de
sport d'excellence à sport quinze jours
mais c'est ce qui est dur aussi parce
que quand tu mets ton je veux dans un
gym puis que le tout le monde sait que
jalouse en imputant ce que je fous le
boss c'est pour son pote
ils s'attendent me voir faire des
marches au losc comme un toit s'est
facilement offert ce oui je capable
d'aller à mener mes jambes à l'abord en
faisant marcher ses mains ça me dérange
pas de faire des gros exercice faut que
tu me manques techniques j'apprends vite
chez une conscience du corps peut-être
plus développé que les hommes mais une
affaire d'ego aussi pour une athlète de
haut niveau de ne plus être au top le
tri d'arrêter puis le de revenir
peut-être un niveau normal ou savoir que
tous les niveaux mais moi ce que j'ai
pas d'orgueil dans le sport que dans le
sens où je suis wheeling d'açaï et tout
parce que j'aime ce fichu poche j'ai du
fun ça me dérange pas puis ça me dérange
pas de regarder les autres me trouvais
poche parce qu'elle a envie j'ai dit
j'ai fait d'autres choses que je n'ai
pas cherché pomper le brut
mais chut games et ça me dérange pas de
ces je n'ai pas peur du ridicule encore
le sécher patiner image pas très fort
c'est correct filles c'est pas grave
mais je le fais par l'idée qu'au lieu de
rester assis et a regardé tout oui mais
on parler de ce jeu thomas tantôt très
douteuse the work it a fait d'autre part
quand même mois le tout ce qui est soit
karaoké tout ce qu'ils demandent l
habileté qu'est-ce que je parle je peux
courir je peux faire du bike energy
c'est pas mal ça va être les sport en
endurance
l'entrée est là j'ai commencé le
crossfit justement à qui ce trouve ça
cool ça faire unique jean phi phi
justement ça me ramène à l'aspect de
gaspé d'avoir un coach est arrivé un
entraînement au tableau tu expliquer
quoi tu le fais un gain dépasse c'est
cool c'est que j'aime vraiment à ceux de
cépie tout le monde sans courage oui
c'est un esprit de gagne oui c'est
compétitif mais tout le monde tu
encourages demande est là pour toi peut
supporter des niveaux notre objectif ce
j'aime ceux de demandes des écoles de
pensée étayé de monde qui vont critique
je pense que ça dépend vraiment de quel
jim et chivu se trouve c'est parce que
je pense pas que maintenant la qualité
d'entraînement et égale partout parce
que c'est pas nécessairement si
standardisés que ceux en même temps si
tôt trente personnes qui font de
crossfit et qu'il y a un entraîneur le
ya un problème
c'est ce que tu peux pas regarder tout
le monde amène rapide je crevais pour
technique et il ya des égos là dedans
qui disent moi je veux lever la charge
horaire mon voisin et l'ait fait que je
le fais mais le coach ne voit pas il se
blesse parce que trop m'en faut que je
trouve un jam ou de 8 ans une gang qui
est un peu moins ltée qui est moins une
personne mais qui là pour te regarder
pour te guider dans ce puits à partir de
exact abssi juste à l'entraînement
complet rapide a été la mentalité que
chaque chaque jour est une heureuse
c'est le fond qui à chaque entraînement
tu voiture et c'est que le voisin c'est
le fun parce que c'est motivant puisse
compétitif mais ça c est fait que un
entraînement sérieux des papables
octobre mais ce qu'il faut c'est que
c'est jamais pareil il ya des exercices
qui reviennent ça c'est sûr ce fait pas
le même entraînement à tous les jours ça
va
violetta spécialisé spleen c'est très
généraliste culte oui tu attrapes et
d'acrobaties au fini la course
même dans les compétitions de la
natation même deux fois en fin de
matinée ce que c'est mais ton qui met
tant que ténor jean habite regarde les
crossfit la norges je trouve ça ridicule
parce qu'ils savent pas d'argent moitié
de ces biens argent là dedans finirait
dix minutes avant tout le monde sauf que
c'est tellement justement large qui
s'est déjà des gens qui sont vraiment à
bord en haltérophilie
c'est vraiment un set games qui ont un
bon cardio socama de courir ici mais
c'est sauter doit faire plus sur un dunk
la natation en eau libre en plus titillé
tout le monde c'est pile est remonté
cette monture
c'est vraiment moche ic phone je pense
qu'il faut juste que je trouve ce parc
est que tu aimes et des coûts de faire
plusieurs fois par semaine soit les
poteaux garder motivés c'est sûr la
chose de plus important c'est plus
important ce que d'avoir le programme
parfait et puis je trouve de kotem fait
régulièrement mais le land'art outin
c'est parce que s'il peut intégrer
tyutin fera jamais site intègre est ta
routine qui s'est bloqué ce temps le
chef est ce ça va marcher ça prend des
mots avant que ce soit vraiment intégré
mais une fois que celle-ci même plus
difficile tu es folle s'intégrer à ta
routine depuis longtemps c'est plus un
effort à chaque fois là je vais
m'entraîner sont en pole
parti doit sa partie c'est normal
complété
c'est ce pin sinon on fait du sport
longtemps tu as beaucoup plus longtemps
que moi puis 4 la fête jeunes aussi
sahara est tellement intégrée dans toi
que une semaine sans faire du sport
c'est comment je me sens comme une
crotte pis écrite de la dopamine qui
tire des affaires qui fait qu'il était
une addiction à samsung de l'addiction
parce que ça aucun effet négatif c'est
juste de gaulle à coup sûr ce merci
beaucoup merci à sa disposition
[Rires]
[Musique]
la hauteur c'est ph
salut c'est d'homme on va sortir un
nouveau podcast à chaque semaine donc
pour nous suivent subscriber youtube
l'acna page facebook piscine ou dans
l'implication balado dans ton téléphone
tu peux aussi commenté les personnes que
tu sois conçoivent ce podcast pichat bas